(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Meet the
husband and wife team
selling a delectable treat
on the streets of Bangkok.
(speaking in foreign language)
The couple met six year ago, when Baitoey
was frequenting Lek's stall.
They eventually were married,
and she joined his business.
Today, they sell a variety
of deep-fried insects
near Khaosan Road, a popular tourist area.
While their menu may vary,
their process is the same.
So, let's start at the beginning,
which is actually the end of the day.
(speaking in foreign language)
And if you think that all bugs
taste the same, think again.
(speaking in foreign language)
Eating bugs used to be associated
with poverty in Thailand, but
that's not the case anymore,
and it's not just tourists
who enjoy this novel treat.
(speaking in foreign language)
But what Lek and Baitoey appreciate most
is the support they provide for each other
each and every day.
(speaking in foreign language)
(jingle)